[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine c'est un challenge est
organisé par le projet d'expérimentation
où une saclay
et donc on fait une semaine ou du vélo
où on invite tous les cyclistes du
plateau de saclay à partager leur trajet
pour pouvoir coter territoire mieux
connaître
les déplacements des cyclistes et
pouvoir ensuite faire la promotion du
vélo à paris 5e c'est un projet qui a
été monté avec les associations
cyclistes à pessac les wind saclay c'est
une démarche initiée par le territoire
qui a mené à différents projets
innovants et un de ces projets s'est
développé une plateforme numérique des
mobilités qui a d'une part un
observatoire des mobilités qui agrège
différentes données du territoire pour
vraiment construire une connaissance
complète de la mobilité et du notre parc
paysager c'est une application pour
concilier une bonne expérience
individuelle de la mobilité avec
l'intérêt général du territoire
l'objectif pour nous une saclay c'est
d'avoir un jeu donnait vraiment axé sur
le vélo pour recenser les trajets les
plus plus emprunter le nombre de
cyclistes et pouvoir croiser ça aussi
avec d'autres données qu'on peut avoir
sur le vélo des boucles de comptage sur
les pistes cyclables pour construire un
premier socle première connaissance du
vélo sur le plateau de saclay
ce projet il est mené par un consortium
public privé avec les communautés
d'agglomération paris saclay et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'université
paris saclay d'instituts vd comme et le
pea paris saclay et l'industriel nokia
bell labs
pour moi le vélo et de modes de
déplacement qui est potentiellement le
plus apte à résoudre les problèmes des
vrais problèmes de déplacement pour un
accès au plateau de saclay
particulièrement pour nous associations
tout ce qui peut favoriser les
déplacements à vélo est à prendre en
contre ça permet aussi de montrer qu'il
existe des itinéraires qu'on appelle
malins qui permettent de rejoindre le
plateau à peu près à peu près à peu près
en sécurité et c'est très important